[Musica]
la tecnologia ha cambiato la nostra vita
e le nostre abitudini
quanti di voi per esempio non hanno un
telefono cellulare in tasca
alzate la mano poche poche persone
quanti di voi per esempio prima appena
si alzano a di alzare la mattina ad
esempio controllate il cellulare entro
la prima mezz'ora provato ad alzare una
mano
ecco qui il numero aumenta
incredibilmente infatti una ricerca dice
che il 57 per cento delle persone
controllo del cellulare entro 22 minuti
dal loro risveglio
pensate che hanno monitorato a 50mila
persone in 32 paesi diversa diverse
quanti di voi invece si addormentano col
telefono in mano durante la notte alzata
mano ecco qui molte 80 per cento delle
persone appunto questa ricerca dice che
si addormentano con il cellulare in
tasca probabilmente quelli che non hanno
altro da mano se ne accorgono perché
cellulare cade non lo so e qualcun altro
lo raccoglie
quanti invece al lavoro guardano il
cellulare per scopi personali
alzate la mano qua io sono sicuro che
molti non alzano la mano perché non
vogliono essere sgamati dal proprio capo
però in realtà sono il 92 per cento
delle persone e infine qui ho il timore
di chiedervelo persone che si svegliano
di notte per controllare le mille di
lavoro è lo so lo so non ve lo chiedo
non ve lo chiedo è il 83 per cento delle
persone
ora voi capite bene che siamo sempre
connesse no
il problema principale è che questo tipo
di connessione avviene questo
comportamento avviene perché il nostro
livello di dopamina si alza e quindi il
2011 è un neurotrasmettitore che
attivare proprio i larici i ricettori
del piacere
e visto che noi pensiamo che appunto
quella notifica ci sta arrivando un
informazione utile un qualcosa di
importante per noi
allora manteniamo il livello di
attivazione sempre alto fino appunto di
controllare in continuazione del
cellulare
ieri sera ero a cena in un ristorante
qua vicino
c'erano due ragazze che hanno per tutta
la serata non hanno mai parlato sempre
attaccati al cellulare addirittura
mangiavano e non vedevano l'uno servano
neanche che cosa stavano per mettendo in
bocca
pensate che li o filmati e non si sono
neanche accorte che li stava filmando
ora è chiaro che questo livello di
attivazione
ci mette nelle condizioni di essere
sempre connessi e infatti che cosa
succede che la tecnologia ha accorciato
tantissimo le distanze provate prende
pensare ad esempio quando telefonavamo a
casa tramite la cabina telefonica non ci
sono più no poi dopo arrivato il
cellulare
adesso abbiamo strumenti come lo
smartwatch che è sempre questo via nella
nuova generazione di smart watch che è
sempre collegato a noi quasi come se
fosse un'appendice del nostro corpo
perché gli scienziati stanno installando
all'interno del cervello del microchip
che ci permettono non solo di migliorare
la nostra memoria e quindi potrebbe
essere qualcosa di utile per esempio per
le persone che hanno delle difficoltà
sulla
ma addirittura per farlo per farci
muovere per esempio degli arti o
addirittura per darci delle informazioni
perché appunto possiamo ottenere
informazioni in continuazione
sembra fantascienza sembra un film di
james bond ma non lo è una qualcosa già
di presente nel mercato e qualcuno di
voi potrà pensare bene così posso
rintracciare immediatamente mia moglie e
la mia compagna no
però attenzione perché anche lei può
rintracciare direttamente vuole sapere
dove siete
ora questo tipo di connessione con
la tecnologia ci mette nelle condizioni
di avere informazioni a nostra
disposizione sempre in continuazione il
15 ottobre di quest'anno mio figlio fa
nove anni
e i nonni hanno deciso di regalargli il
google.com che probabilmente qualcuno di
voi conosce è un assistente virtuale è
un assistente virtuale è che è connesso
sempre con la rete mio figlio può
chiedere informazioni a google home in
continuazione con ad esempio la sera e
chiede a google di mandare la sua musica
preferita la musica di harry potter
quindi noi ci addormentiamo con la
musica di harry potter punta la sveglia
la mattina la mattina si sveglia gli
chiede come sarà la sua giornata e
google gli risponde gli risponde per
esempio con il tempo e gli dice quanto
come sarà la il clima del che si troverà
durante la giornata e poi gli risponde
visto che è connesso con il mio account
gli racconta tutti i miei appuntamenti
mio figlio è diventato ancora più
informato della mia segretaria sugli
appuntamenti
mia moglie non chiede pure una
segretaria chi da mio figlio
direttamente ma la cosa che però lo
rendeva un po triste era il fatto che
google rom gli rispondeva con il nome
diego perché appunto è connesso col mio
account
allora io a un certo punto gli ho detto
ma parlo perché non gli chiede di
chiamarti edoardo così gli chiese di
richiamarlo edoardo e immediatamente
google home lo chiamo edoardo cioè
apprende apprende e risponde rispetto ai
nostri bisogni
apprendiamo anche noi però dalla
dell'intelligenza artificiale cioè ad
esempio
mio figlio è diventato ad esempio il
numero uno a scuola per raccontare
barzellette perché ogni giorno gli
chiede a google una decina di
barzellette poi se li rivende a scuola
praticamente e
fino a un punto in cui un giorno entra
in casa e stava facendo i compiti e
angelo stava studiando gli egizi e
chiede a google per esempio gli chiede
per chi avesse scoperto la tomba di
tutankhamon
a quel punto dopo un paio d'ore eravamo
in macchina e gli dico edoardo mar
quindi che ha scoperto la tomba di
tutankhamon e lui mi dice non me lo
ricordo è perché non te lo ricordi
perché intanto se cielo bisogno lo
chiedo lui rom
abbiamo pensato che forse era il caso di
staccarlo abbiamo disconnesso e ci siamo
accorti praticamente che dopo un paio di
giorni tutti i due nostri figli ci
chiedevano dove era andato a finire o
google perché perché gli mancava ma non
gli mancava perché attenzione non gli
mancava perché li avessero facilitati
nel negli studi gli mancava perché
mancava un componente della famiglia
quello è la cosa molto preoccupante lo
sa molto bene il preside di una scuola
di una scuola qua vicino al liceo
scientifico di piacenza che ha
introdotto quest'anno questo un
sacchettino dove gli studenti di non
metterlo dentro il loro cellulare è
totalmente schermato e non possono
sostanzialmente più telefonare possono
riprendere il cellulare alla fine delle
lezioni attraverso la banda magnetica
che sono gli insegnanti a dover
sbloccare anche gli insegnanti devono
dare buon esempio beh vediamo che cosa
succede come hanno preso questa
situazione gli studenti del liceo come è
stata la prima lezione senza cellulare
qualcosa di terrificante non lo augura a
nessuno perché veramente io sono una che
molto c'è continua a controllare
l'orario un e che comunque sia c'è non
so come dire però però è stato veramente
terrificante continuavo a chiedere le
mie amiche che avevano l'orologio
l'orario e cioè snervante tortura sì
veramente una tortura una delle peggiori
per me siamo un po tutti i volontari
ecco sono tutti contrari all'apertura
dell'app è la peggior tortura in realtà
quello di terrificante il fatto che noi
stiamo diventando schiavi della
tecnologia addirittura stiamo perdendo
la nostra capacità naturale ad esempio
di sentire di percepire il pilot di
trascorrere del tempo ad esempio questo
è terrificante
e chiaro che il problema principale è
questo ma c'è una fattore secondario
importante che la tecnologia ci aiuta ci
aiuta anche in maniera semplice ci
facilita la vita
io per esempio per esempio qualcuno mi
dice ma diego io quando non c'era la
tecnologia mi ricordavo i numeri di
telefono a memoria si è vero però quanti
numeri vi ricordavate 10 15 20 numeri di
telefono
io adesso quattromila e cinquecento
contatti nella mia rubrica che possa
accedere in 30 secondi forse meno
schiaccia un pulsantino quando finisce
la carta igienica è collegato al mio
account e mi ordina in 24 ore la carta
igienica
così faccio per la carta di caffè per
l'acqua mi agevolata tantissimo la vita
è il problema è che cos'è che tutto
questo processo
gli americani lo chiamano instant
gratification cioè gratificazione
istantanea la gratificazione istantanea
è un grosso problema per la nostra
società perché abbiamo perso il gusto
per esempio dell'aspettare abbiamo tutto
subito
possiamo ottenere tutto quello che
vogliamo in pochi click e questo
meccanismo è un meccanismo vizioso
perché ti mette nelle condizioni anche
la società di richiedere persone sempre
più veloci
la lentezza
l'abbiamo visto molto bene oggi con
alcuni speech la lentezza
alla fine ti crea ansia hai bisogno di
una società rapida io l'altra sera ho
visto un film di alberto sordi mi piace
molto alberto sordi ma è una generazione
sicuramente diversa e mi rendo conto che
proprio le tempistiche di quei film
erano completamente diverse rispetto
alle tempistiche di oggi allora questa
rapidità ci porta poi a escluderci dalla
società abbiamo visto per esempio con
l'intervento di sarà il primo intervento
del ted che la società ci porta ad avere
un modello di riferimento che un corpo
perfetto no che molte persone appunto
anno questa difficoltà e quindi in
giappone 600mila bambini adolescenti
sono totalmente chiusi e rinchiusi nelle
loro case connessi alla tecnologia
perché hanno paura di uscire di casa ci
portano a si chiama gli hikikomori
questo questo movimento e ci porta a non
volere più relazionarci con il nostro
corpo ci porta proprio a escluderci dal
punto di vista relazionale hanno tutto
di quello di cui hanno bisogno possono
mangiare avere tutto in casa collegarsi
con con il mondo ma non sono connessi
con loro stesse perché perché non
riescono praticamente ad avere delle
relazioni umane nel senso della
relazione con un corpo umano
e allora visto che manca questo aspetto
cosa hanno fatto gli scienziati mar
semplicissimo costruiamo qualcuno che ci
assomiglia costruiamo abbiamo visto il
robottino ma costruiamo robot sempre più
somiglianti a noi questo è un robot che
assomiglia
johansson che un'attrice americana
considerata tra le più belle attrici gli
stati uniti e e fa di tutto fa anche le
espressioni facciali come vedete cerca
di trasmetterci sostanzialmente le
emozioni che lei tra virgolette sta
provando in realtà ovviamente non prova
emozione ma la società che più sta
investendo su questi robot e la società
del sesso ovviamente perché hanno tanti
soldi e questo signore un signore di 70
anni ad atlanta ha comprato april e per
il costa 45 mila dollari e dice di far
sesso con april quattro volte alla
settimana e la moglie è molto contenta
perché non lo tradisce
ora voi pensate anche al fatto che non
solo ci soddisfa i bisogni carnali di
questa persona ma addirittura se la
porta anche a cena
secondo me perché costa meno della
moglie però è una mia interpretazione e
poi se sono gentili carini soddisfano i
nostri bisogni sono pazienti ovviamente
molto più pazienti minori perché non
dargli la cittadinanza
lei è sofia e della prima robot che ha
la cittadinanza saudita nel nostro sulla
nostra terra
ora capito che stiamo andando verso una
direzione che ci mette nelle condizioni
di avere sempre di più relazioni non
umane la fed computing è una
branca della scienza che ci mette nelle
condizioni sostanzialmente di studiare
le emozioni e di osservare le emozioni
umane riconoscerla in questo caso il
computer ha riconosciuti emozione come
state provando e trasmettervi le stesse
emozioni che questo che provando
utilizzando un po la tecnica dei neuroni
a specchio ma secondo voi
a questo punto una riflessione non
volevo volevo proporvi perché nel
dicembre del 2009 google decide di
inserire nei loro loggare quindi ricerca
un sistema per cui tutte le ricerche che
voi fate in questo momento sono legate
alle ricerche precedenti che avevate
fatto è come se vuoi entraste in una
libreria con un sacco di libero la
possibilità di conoscere un sacco di
cose e qualcuno vi porta in una stanza
dove ci sono solo dei pochi libri che
sono selezionati sulla base dei libri
che avevate letto precedentemente è
chiaro che viene meno la vostra capacita
invece di esplorare un po il mondo ma
tutto questo avviene viene fatto se voi
ci pensate tutto quello che abbiamo
visto in questa giornata viene fatto per
facilitarci la vita lo fanno per fare in
modo che le nostre decisioni siano più
una più rapida che sia tutto più facile
ma quindi che cosa che manca cioè se voi
foste sofia il robot cittadino saudita
che cos'è che invii di arresto a noi
provate a pensarci che cosa che nvidia
restano insegue i foste il robot sofia
io penso che un elemento che manca è
sicuramente il corpo
manca il nostro sistema nervoso autonomo
il fatto che sentite la mia agitazione
le mie la mia respirazione
il mio rossore tutto ciò che riguarda i
miei sentimenti le mie emozioni voi
riuscite a riconoscerle le avete
riconosciute in tutta questa giornata su
noi speaker ma anche nelle emozioni che
avete provato buono vi siete tenuti per
mano ad esempio e con manca il corpo
mancano le emozioni mancano i sentimenti
manca un aspetto fondamentale
mancano le difficoltà perché solo
attraverso le difficoltà noi possiamo
imparare a crescere il bambino che
impara a camminare impara un processo
che complessissimo voi pensate che siamo
gli animali
pochissimi sono gli animali quelli che
camminano sulle zampe proprio perché
perché è molto complesso come processo e
le difficoltà ci aiutano a crescere ci
aiutano ad affrontare anche la vita e
diventare più resilienti oggi si parla
molto della resilienza se ci manca
questo ci manca una componente
fondamentale
la scienza ha dimostrato che quando noi
facilitiamo il processo ai nostri figli
da un punto di vista pedagogico a dire
sempre di sì ad esempio crescono bambini
che nella loro vita avranno sempre dei
problemi da un punto di vista per
esempio dell'esplorare le loro passioni
perché per esplorare la propria passione
bisogna far fatica hanno dimostrato che
questi bambini nasceranno con delle
competenze emotive molto basse non
riusciranno ad affrontare le difficoltà
le emozioni quelle più difficile
sappiamo molto bene che ci sono emozioni
che vengono definite impropriamente
emozioni negative ma non sono affatto
negative sono in realtà positive queste
emozioni perché attraverso la tristezza
ad esempio noi riusciamo a recuperare
noi riusciamo a a fare in modo che gli
altri sappiano che abbiamo bisogno di
loro
la rabbia ci fa raggiungere degli
obiettivi quindi esplorare l'emozione in
toto a 360 gradi e soprattutto a
diventare consapevoli a livello emotivo
ci mette nelle condizioni di essere
connesse non ad una ad una vita virtuale
ma ad una vita reale
quindi il mio esorto per voi è quello di
esplorare le difficoltà di vivere una
vita consapevole a livello emotivo il
più possibile e di uscire un po dagli
schemi perché quando noi vediamo questa
bambina che gioca con le bolle di sapone
noi sappiamo che questa bambina
immaginerà l'immaginabile
il immaginabile per me pensare di poter
vivere in un mondo popolato da robot che
ci possano sostituire perché per me non
esiste un emozione senza un corpo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]